- This one kid in my
sixth grade math class
called me pit stain,
but then I bullied him back really hard,
and I regret that to this day.
- [Female Host] Is there anything
you were teased or bullied about,
like a name you were
called that stuck with you?
- I won't say who called me
it, because it was so long ago,
but I remember being called this a lot.
- Classic!
- Classic.
- Which, by the way, is not a bad thing.
- So, did people make fun of your laugh?
- Oh my God, I've been
in the middle of shows,
and people have turned to me
and been like, "You
have a terrible laugh."
- Well, I'm always being teased
for my big teeth, or my eyebrows,
or anything it is, on social media.
- Your eyebrows?
- Yes.
- I was just gonna say,
your eyebrows are so great!
- Well, thank you.
- When I was a kid,
kids would kinda tease me a
little bit about acting stuff.
- Even when you're J-Lo's son?
- Well, that's what they
would tease me for, you know.
Kids are mean.
- When I was younger, I was
a huge tomboy, I still am,
and people used to tease me about that.
- Yeah.
- I have really long hair,
and I've had long hair my whole life,
so people would tease me with that.
- Really?
- Yeah!
- You know, I was teased
a lot about being short,
and my hair, and like all this stuff.
- I'm right there with you
on the short one, by the way.
All the time I got called short.
Is there any advice you'd give to someone
who's being teased or bullied?
- I encourage everyone
that, you know, feels alone,
to go online and find friends.
Hey, that's how we got together!
- Yay!
- What's for you, is what's for you.
So, what you got going on,
you make sure you own it.
- If you find an activity
that you love to do,
and you have people that
are like-minded like you,
you'll find your friend
and your support system.
- As you grow older, you realize that
all the things you think
weren't cool about you,
are what make you stick
out later in a good way.
- All hate comes from some kind of love.
- Roll off your back,
laugh with 'em, and--
- And become a superhero!
- That's right.
- Tell an adult.
I think that's number one,
that people never want to do.
- You have to speak up.
It's very important,
because these days and times,
know that the action can be taken care of.
- They're doing it for other reasons
other than the fact that
you're weaker than them.
It's really sad.
- That person has been
taught that behavior in their home life,
so they are probably
being teased and bullied
by the adults that surround them.
And that's not gonna
make you feel any better,
it's just kinda a way of
practicing compassion,
so that you don't interpret it
as something that's
specifically happening to you.
- So, all the people
who called me a tomboy,
I wanna say, you're totally right.
I still am and I'm so proud of it.
- I am extra!
I'm so extra.
I'm over-the-top and I'm loud,
and I would rather be too
big than be too small.
- We all know that monkeys
are known for climbing things.
So, look at me now, I'm climbing
my way to the top, dammit.
- I started from the bottom, now I'm here.
- Oh!
(upbeat music)
(squeaking)